[Musique]
amani la scène a dépassé les 4 mètres
cinquante de la côte d' alerte le
dispositif de sécurité a été mis en
oeuvre
sur les quais les plus bas on a commencé
à dresser des digues supplémentaires de
ciment
non
on a colmaté les égouts ou entouré les
bouches d'égout de mur de sécurité
toutes précautions ont été prises pour
éviter le désastre de 1910 année
terrible où l'on vit la scène sur le
parvis de notre-dame et les députés
obligés de se rendre à la chambre en
bateau si la gare saint-lazare baigner
dans l'eau c'était bien pis du côté de
la gare des invalides
plus question d'y prendre le train tout
au plus aurait-on pu s'y promener en
barque
[Musique]
les stations de métro s'était transformé
en piscine et l'esplanade des invalides
était au lac le paris de 1910 c'était
une espèce de venise improviser sans
gondole ni romance où l'on quittait le
bateau pour la passerelle de planches et
où la vie devenait un tour de force
[Musique]
les parisiens qui se souviennent de 1910
ne tiennent pas à recommencer
[Musique]